boa tarde a todos
eu sou educador diante dessas palavras
d'alessandro eu digo pra vocês que eu
sou educador antes de ser educadores o
farmacêutico paraense nascido e criado
em belém na cidade velha daqueles que
tomam atacar todo domingo à tarde quando
támbém sol eo meu filho do meio já me
acompanha comigo mas em 1998 eu decidi
que eu queria ser profissional da área
da saúde
com 17 anos eu falei eu quero ser
profissional da área da saúde
fiz o vestibular da ufpa e passa em
farmácia e fiquei muito feliz muito
empolgado e resolvi contar isso para uma
pessoa que eu queria admiração que eu
queria que me desse força e essa pessoa
disse que eu não conseguiria ter sucesso
na vida sem farmacêutico e como eu sou
meio do contra
resolvi assim eu acho que eu vou fazer
diferente
comecei a cursar a faculdade com toda
empolgação duas semanas depois greve
greve dos professores
foi bom não vou parar vou continuar vou
me envolver e aí vivendo a graduação em
farmácia buscava no farmacêutico ser um
profissional da saúde
e aí eu descobri que o farmacêutico eu
tinha um pouco de dificuldade de
entender com formações poderia ser
profissional da saúde
eu vi com um cientista que desenvolvi eu
gostava muito de química que desenvolver
medicamentos que podia produzir
medicamentos ou trabalhava nas análises
clínicas fazendo análise em equipamentos
superavançados então eu vejo mais como
um cientista e na graduação a gente vai
num ritmo tão longo tão grande focado em
conhecimento que muitas vezes a gente
não tem tempo para pensar é prova
seminário trabalho monografia uma coisa
atrás da outra a gente não pára pra
pensar
isso é que faz parte da nossa estrutura
educacional
até que quando me formei eu comecei a
ter um pouquinho de tempo mais pra parar
e pensar sobre o que é ser um
profissional da área da saúde
e aí eu comecei a fazer alguns links
algumas conexões de várias informações
soltas que eu tinha já trabalhando já no
mercado de trabalho ainda não trabalhava
com o ensino com docência e aí eu
comecei a conectar e comecei a ver a
realidade que me cercava a realidade da
saúde no país na amazônia em belém
e aí um dos dados que começou a saltar
os meus olhos foi a questão do
envelhecimento da população fenômeno que
tinha acontecido na europa década estava
começando a acontecer no brasil e aí o
salto de envelhecimento estava muito
grande ea projeção do próprio ibge para
2020 é que doem do ano 2000 para 2020
os idosos no brasil dobre a população as
doenças crônicas também crescem
consideravelmente com o avançar da idade
se as pessoas envelhecem mais ficam
idosas e acabam vivendo por mais anos
também convivem com doenças crônicas em
sua maioria então é aos 20 anos de idade
e 23% da pessoa as pessoas têm doenças
crônicas
mas até os 79 anos de idade próxima aos
80 anos quase 80% das pessoas têm alguma
doença crônica
chegando ao ponto que 31% dos
brasileiros adultos de uma maneira geral
relatam afirmam ter algum tipo de doença
crônica e eu como farmacêutico tentando
enxergar onde encaixar nisso porque o
avanço tecnológico todas as áreas da
área da saúde medicina nutrição
enfermagem farmácia avançando tudo
progredindo e eu tentando me encontrar
nesse contexto até que o ministério da
saúde
soltam um estudo que me conecta muito
mais a problemática que a gente vive na
área da saúde e 82% dos pacientes que
são pole medicados que tomam vários
medicamentos por dia que essa é a
realidade que a gente vive
medicalização os medicamentos são visto
como a salvação para algum problema
qualquer problema que nós temos existe
um medicamento que vai resolver esse
problema é se a mãe é a mentalidade que
circula no um inconsciente coletivo 82%
essas pessoas têm algum problema que
envolve a omissão de dose ou a
descontinuação indevida freqüência de
horário adesão ao tratamento confusão
troca de medicamentos e isso gera ao
descontrole da doença crônica problemas
relacionados a medicamentos
e aí vem um outro dado que também me fez
cair sentado que apenas o paciente
crônico durante um ano inteiro ele ele
passa apenas três horas de todo o ano
dele em contato com algum profissional
da área da saúde
um paciente que tem uma duas três e
hipertenso diabético renal crônico em
média ele passa apenas três horas do ano
desde em contato com um profissional da
área da saúde é um dado chocante e aí eu
pensei em algo errado eu tenho que fazer
a diferença é possível fazer a diferença
como eu posso fazer isso na minha
profissão é difícil encontrar o caráter
de profissional da área da saúde porque
o farmacêutico em 98 não tinha o contato
com o cuidado tinha pouco contato com o
paciente
apesar de que no mundo inteiro já tinha
mudado europa canadá estados unidos
austrália farmacêutico já era voltado
para do cuidado eu entendi que essa
mudança no brasil demorou porque o
envelhecimento da população demorou
também e aí eu disse chegou a hora de
voltar e para o cuidado a área do
cuidado com a emissão de qualquer
profissional da área da saúde gente
cuidar de pessoas
não interessa qual profissão ele siga a
missão dele é cuidar de pessoas e aí pra
cuidar de pessoas precisam desenvolver
habilidades humanas não tem com quem eu
vou lidar com outra pessoa eu tenho que
desenvolver as habilidades humanas
as máquinas estão devendo à área da
robótica
a tecnologia e vocês são da área da
tecnologia em sua maioria sabe que o
desenvolvimento é muito grande e logo
logo a cada vez mais as máquinas
substituem os seres humanos mas nas
habilidades humanas isso é diferente ea
gente é a gente carece de
desenvolvimento de habilidades humanas
então chegou a hora de mudar
esse é um relatório do fórum econômico
mundial que destaca como projeção para
o top 10 e habilidades humanas a ser
desenvolvidas para qualquer profissão e
aí a gente pode destacar como um top 10
no top 10 na solução de problemas
complexos profissionais da área da saúde
são resolvedores de problemas todos
a missão dele é tentar resolver o
problema é o dia a dia do profissional
da área da saúde bem como o pensamento
crítico a criatividade em momentos de
crise a criatividade destaca mais ainda
gestão de pessoas à empatia com os
outros a empatia com os outros foco em
mobilidade humana importantíssima que é
a habilidade de comunicação saber se
comunicar
inteligência emocional bom senso e
tomada de decisão orientação para os
serviços negociação e flexibilidade
cognitiva como é possível fazer que o
hipertenso que têm diagnóstico médico
prescrição de medicamentos fez exames
laboratoriais consiga aderir ao seu
tratamento tem um dado que diz que um
terço dos hipertensos com diagnóstico e
prescrição não tomam os medicamentos
e por conta disso tem complicações
agravadas internações
então chegou a hora de desenvolver
habilidades humanas e nesse relatório do
top 10 tem uma habilidade humana que
precisa ser muito desenvolvida
principalmente na área da saúde que é a
solidariedade a solidariedade é
fundamental para qualquer profissional
da área da saúde
então como é que a gente muda isso gente
colocando a mão na massa
ninguém aprende a dirigir sem pegar um
carro e ninguém aprende a cozinhar sem
colocar a mão nos ingredientes e pra
cuidar de pessoas é preciso lidar com
pessoas ter contato com pessoas e foi aí
que eu comecei a estudar já como
professor na área da educação e aí esse
é o cone de aprendizagem de deus década
de 80 e lá ele disse assim o quê apenas
10% do que nós lemos
daqui a duas semanas nós conseguimos
guardar apenas 10% de tudo que a gente
lê como é a formação da gente na
graduação lê ouvir palestras ea idéia o
dia seguinte que 90% do que a gente
experiência o que a gente vive seja com
apresentação gramática simulando um
atendimento real fazendo a coisa real é
absorvido fica um aprendizado
isso chama-se de memória emotiva toda
vez que a gente vive uma emoção durante
o aprendizado as nossas conexões
sinápticas elas consolidam aquela
informação e ela fica registrada ao
advogado já falou também na
psicopedagogia que não existe um tipo de
inteligência existem inteligências
múltiplas a gente precisa desenvolver
cada uma delas
quem trabalha na área da saúde não pode
apenas saber de inteligência lógica
matemática dominar os conteúdos
ele precisa ter habilidade de
comunicação desenvolver todo o tipo de
inteligência porque o foco maior dele é
o paciente
e aí foi que surgiu a oportunidade de
colocar em prática isso dentro de uma
pós-graduação e na graduação utilizando
um método uma metodologia ativa chamada
de simulação realística
existe um mito na área da saúde gente
que os profissionais da área da saúde
não podem errar
desculpa decepcioná los mas os
profissionais da área da saúde são seres
humanos e erram erram muito mais do que
se imagina
muito mais do que nós conseguimos
mensurar
por conta disso na no momento do estudo
seja na graduação e na pós-graduação ele
pode trabalhar com uma metodologia
simulado onde os pacientes não são reais
onde pacientes são atores treinados em
um ambiente controlado e que se
acontecer deu errado de escolher uma
conduta diferente da correta eu posso
aprender com aquele erro e não errar na
vida real
então a metodologia ativa de simulação
realística envolve vários cenários desde
uma consulta simples de acompanhamento
situação de conflito comportamentais
paciente que dificuldade de aceitação do
problema de saúde
situações éticas situações
multiprofissionais olha uma simulação
multiprofissional diversos profissionais
da área da saúde junto treinando a
possibilidade de aprender conjuntamente
isso acontece de forma programada
controlada filmada que ela pode ser
discutida posteriormente o
posicionamento de todos
no contato com o paciente existem mais
de 80 cenários elaborados e preparados
para isso todos os atores envolvidos são
treinados alguns deles são inclusive
profissionais da área da saúde o que faz
com que a gente tenha um ambiente o
máximo controlado possível não deixando
de lado o improviso porque a vida real é
cheia de improvisos
após as simulações os próprios
farmacêuticos e profissionais da área da
saúde reavaliam a sua postura dentro do
cenário e discutem se observam vemos os
seus erros o que pode ser melhorado isso
é feito uma discussão em conjunta os
erros são discutidos é bom falar de
erros gente é bom falar de erro para não
errar de novo quanto mais se fala de
erro é melhor e aí errando um ambiente
simulado é muito melhor para não errar
junto com o paciente
isso desenvolve aquela habilidade que eu
falei pra vocês
anteriormente que é a solidariedade uma
boa parte dos alunos de pós graduação
que já trabalham no dia a dia já são
profissionais já estão no mercado
descobrem na pós graduação que podem
trabalhar solidariedade essa questão
diversas ações motivadas pelos alunos da
pós-graduação para atendimento da
comunidade carente atendimento de
rastreamento a saúde de controle de
encaminhamento inclusive outros
profissionais dos mais diversos que eles
relatam experiências incríveis como esse
pessoal estou trabalhando há dez anos eu
não porque eu não fiz isso antes porque
não fui solidário antes porque eu dou o
meu conhecimento antes e fiquei tanto
tempo parado no mercado
aí eu deixo essa mensagem para vocês
como um profissional da área da saúde
pode pensar em cuidado se ele não
consegue trabalhar as habilidades
humanas
mario quintana disse que não ficou com
quem não compreende um olhar tão pouco
compreenderá uma longa explicação
obrigado